Let's analyze some of the benefits
of coded aperture here.
Basically, we looked at
variety of different you know,
types of kernels here, larger scale,
correct scale, and a smaller scale.
And, of course, we have the coded
apertures, of course, also scaled down.
If you had an image like this to be
reconstructed on a conventional the,
again, Lucy Richardson types
of deconvolution method,
you'd get a lot of ringing.
Of course, if we do it at the correct
scale so the size of the kernel matches
the kind of signal that's in the
original image, you'll do much better.
But of course,
if you do it a smaller scale,
you actually will add
other forms of blur.
Of course,
the secret is to figure out which of
these scales to do this kind of stuff.
We've looked at that concept, and
we looked all the frequency,
domain, fading, and blending stuff.
But in case of coded,
of course we have an artifact
that we might actually generate
something like this, but
we actually do get a much better
image at the right scale.
And of course,
a little bit of blurriness and
ringing at the scale that's smaller.
I do loo, encourage you to look at the
Levinthal paper, that'll gives you more
detail about this kind of stuff and
how to choose the right scale.